[موسيقى]
هل صحيح انه كان في قاده عرب متاثرين جدا
عن لقائك بهم بحاله صدام حسين في المعتقل
صف لنا ذلك واذا كان في يعني امكانيه لذكر
اسماء ايضا
في احد اللقاءات مع احد القاده العرب
الماء اوصف له يعني الرجل كان يصغي ورد
يسمع من عندي ومده لقاء كانت 55 دقيقه
كافيه ادما كنت اوصف له الوضع كان متاثر
جدا واكد لي امام مدير مخابراته وامام
نائبه انه الرئيس صدام حسين والعراق كان
سدا بني عن بين الدول العربيه وبين الفرس
وسيعمل هذا القائد العربي كل باب وسعه
لاخراج الرئيس من هذا المطب اللي هو فيه
القائد العربي الاخر ادنى وصفت له يعني
وضع الرئيس
وما جرى الى بكى ثلاث مرات
متاثرا بوضعه بكى امامك ثلاث مرات امامي
ثلاث مرات يعني على فترات متقطعه خلال مده
المقابله بسبب
الرئيس وما قال اليه الوضع ووضع العراق
ايضا يعني كان يشيد بفضل العراق وفي اي
شخصيه من هاتين شخصيتين يمكن ان تسميها
نعم لبكره ثلاث مرات المرحوم معمر القذافي
كان متاثر جدا
[موسيقى]
ما الذي ذكره الرئيس الاسبق صدام حسين
للمحامين الثلاثه في اللقاء الاخير الذي
لم تحضره ثلاث مرات يعني اقدم على القدوم
ويمنعني الجانب الامريكي ويمنع احد زملائي
ايضا هو نائب رئيس الدفاع
يعني منعه من زياره موكله كان وكيل
المرحوم طاهر رمضان
فمن اتصل بجانب الامريكي وبعثت الزملاء
والتقوا ويا مع الرئيس
ابلغوه بالمصادق على حكم الاعدام
فاكدوا لهم انه اني انتظر هذا اليوم وانا
متوقعه ودائما كان يقدرنا انه اني طلقت
الحياه من عام 1959 عندما ضربت عبد الكريم
قاسم انا ايضا حكمت بالاعدام ومحكوم عده
مرات بالاعدام فما بالتاس يعني استقبل
الموضوع برحابه صدر وبعد فيها برساله يعني
للشعب العراقي هي يعني رساله وداع ووصيه
بنفس الوقت انه لا تحقدوا
الشعب الامريكي ولا على الشعوب اللي اللي
اجت وغزتنا لكن الحقد او الكراهيه تكون
لقادتهم
[موسيقى]